ça reste un mystère trente ans après les
faits en 1991 un homme se retrouve est
suspecté du meurtre d'une femme
son nom omar haddad
le point tout de suite sur cette affaire
qui est un véritable roman policier 24
juin 1991 ghislaine marchal est
retrouvée assassinée chez elle dans sa
chaufferie à mougins très vite omar
haddad un marocain de 29 ans et
jardinier de la victime est suspecté en
cause une phrase écrite sur les lieux du
meurtre sur la porte inscrite en lettres
de sang cette petite phrase omar m'a
tuer omar m'a tuer d'après la police
ghislaine marchal est l'auteur de
l'inscription omar haddad est arrêté
mais mis à part cet élément aucune
preuve ne le relié au crime les analyses
ont révélé qu'il n'y avait aucune trace
d'omar raddad sur madame marchal ou dans
la chaufferie ni aucune trace de la
chaufferie ou de madame marchal sur omar
haddad malgré les faibles charges omar
haddad reste le suspect numéro un trois
ans plus tard le 24 janvier 1994 son
procès s'ouvre à nice devant une salle
comble les redites 18 ans de prison
colère de son avocat jacques vergès
quelqu'un dont j'ai prouvé l'innocence a
été condamné à une peine à une peine
qu'il ne mérite pas mais la sphère ne
s'arrête pas là
10 mai 1996 sur la demande du roi hassan
ii du maroc le président jacques chirac
accorde une grâce partielle à omar
haddad l'ancien jardinier libéré le 4
septembre 1998 après sept ans de prison
aujourd'hui bien sûr je tente d'affréter
descendeur
parce que j'en donne même le choix libre
et mais en même temps je souhaite pas
libre passant pour ça car cette grâce
partielle n'innocente pas omar haddad
pour autant il reste coupable du meurtre
de ghislaine marchal mais en 2001 coup
de théâtre
la police fait une découverte sur la
porte de la chaufferie de la victime un
adn masculin et retrouver adn qui ne
correspond pas à celui d'omar raddad
partir du moment où on ne trouve pas son
adn sur la porte ça prouve et ce que dit
la défense qui n'était pas là au moment
des faits grâce à cette nouvelle preuve
omar haddad demande la révision de son
procès requête rejetée par la cour de
révision le 20 novembre 2002 aujourd'hui
pour moi senna justice et pas juste et
jusqu'au beau jeu combat jusqu'à la fin
de ma vie dix neuf ans plus tard en 2021
nouvelle requête de la part d'omar
raddad cette demande de révision fait
suite à de nouveaux adn découvert en
2000 qu'un sur des scellés et qui
n'appartiennent pas omar haddad réponse
de la commission d'instruction ce jeudi
[Musique]